too many people want social content to
do everything instead of being the moose
boosh to the thing you want them to do i
think for example i would tell you that
i'm incredibly misunderstood as a
businessman because my social media
content can't do the depths of what i do
there is no videos where i'm talking
like this where i can i like who i am as
an actual business person does not
really show up with my social i just let
my social
do the appetizer part and then with the
hopes that people will go down the path
and a lot of times where you have depth
and you have a real business you get
caught up because you're trying to make
a little bit more happen in the content
which doesn't mean being authentic and
just do whatever will work on social but
think strategically of like what will
this tick tock do when they decide to
click the default url in our profile
instead of maybe trying to make two or
three things happen in a piece awesome
so maybe we can go around and maybe just
do some intros and tell me what business
you're in and then we'll go
into kind of the
direct q a time to be
selfish and just ask away at your
questions so yeah sorry i'm here yeah
alice kim i have a sustainable women's
wear company for ladies with a larger
chest so double d who are not plus size
so size 0 to 14
underserved demographic so we're
eliminating the shame by um we're
changing the game by eliminating the
change that's what we say
where are you based new york awesome
chris mcclure out of chicago um i have a
family-owned print business and so
kind of looking to how do we evolve as
uh as businesses have kind of evolved
evolved yes and how do we integrate
those
things very cool how long has the
company been around
uh well 80 years
um it's amazing this piece of it 30 some
that's part of the challenge is we're
known
for a certain segment of our
business we have to go fast because it's
a
changing curtain yeah understood thanks
for being here thank you
brody hansen i make a clean label energy
drink called work water
it's uh
i made it for myself i was a working
professional you know 15 years as an
engineer management consultant and two
monsters a day it turns out it's not a
healthy thing
so
i created this to solve a couple
problems one is the ingredients
themselves so
no more multiple stimulants no more
artificial ingredients there's only five
ingredients on the label um all natural
and the second is the aesthetic i was
tired of you know putting a rainbow
shooting fireworks
at work
and so we're now at the point of
so we're now at the point where uh got
the production of the beverage
solid it took me over two years to get
to that point wrong yeah of course of
course so now i get to do the fun part
which is come here and figure out how to
make the world aware of it and get it
sold and you're a champion right yes
eastern canada cool brody was actually
here two years ago he flew in for the
40s right before the shutdown he had
dinner with nick and so we're really
stoked that he was able to come out for
this
i ran into so many problems after that
that all this stuff would have had to
wait anyway so very cool
pleasure
real pleasure bernie hi i'm alex
finnelli my business partner tim moran
and i uh own and operate fat scooters
which is an electric two-wheel electric
vehicle
company that started originally in 2017.
we were the largest investor in the
company
what was that
we were the senior creditors to the
company took over the company about a
year ago understood turned it around and
now
uh now that the company has been
readjusted
to be a profitable platform now we're
actually looking to scale that sure
good for you guys awesome we brought
jeremy in with them jeremy's uh a good
friend of the family he's been bringing
a lot of companies into the 4ds so he
happened to be aware and we decided it's
awesome good to see you again
good you already heard my story sir
i'm billy richardson i was in l.a last
time so i was so impressed
and so i
got um for my sister for christmas
that's amazing
so cool social media and stuff like that
and i thought
i thought she would learn a ton of stuff
so it's great to see you gambling hi i'm
melissa
um and i have a social first platform
called particulars uh where i basically
talk about all things fashion
accessories related and then as part of
that i have an interview series so i've
interviewed over 100 female founders and
tell their stories and we always tie it
back to their particulars what's
particular to you is completely
different
than what's particular to me um i just
launched my first product very cool the
nice pack um need in case of emergency
so this was definitely kind of during
the pandemic i wanted
i wasn't carrying like my celine bag or
sure i was going for my patagonia fanny
pack or my like shitty amazon of course
um but nothing had exposed pockets on
the outside so there's pockets for all
of your particulars also so like your
phone can fit in your air pods but or it
could be your i don't know hand
sanitizer sure um i produce everything
in la and we started selling them in
october and it's doing well so
looking to really ramp this up and also
try to figure out how to monetize the
particulars and figure out what to do
with my interview series that's
different than or or replicate what has
naturally come to you which is continue
to just
build up the particulars as a leverage
point to more
product and in the consumer business
understood awesome
my name is charles weiner i'm here with
my team um named my company is the
handsome home buyer i have a vertically
integrated real estate development firm
i'm hung out in new york where we fix
and put volumes of houses into
commercial development and now i have a
company where we're 3d printing houses
out of concrete as well as the interior
pieces out of our recycled plastic
models interesting
very cool
um
pam i do like marketing and social media
that's awesome
my name is levy i'm his videographer
editor content creator it's awesome it's
a pleasure to meet you guys
controversial topic um i'm
tapping into category that the fashion
industry really hasn't tapped into so
there's regular size makes all the sense
in the world so you're a size inclusive
but we're not shape inclusive so i'm a
size zero or two and i can't fit into
half the clothes when i was banker
before i went into fashion button downs
gave open suit jackets don't close with
yeah
so
figuring this out do you know how big
the dressable market is 20 million women
so 68 20 million
in the u.s so 68 of women are plus size
so size 16 and up yep so the balance 32
about that 350 is a to c cup versus d
cuts it up so if you look in the room
right now majority of us fall into the
demographic yep yes so um
this is you know data for you right here
sure
so i have patent pending style so button
down sports bra is coming it's a
lifestyle brand but how do i become the
lululemon the spanx of the world
dominating this category when a lot of
editors and stuff they don't even want
to touch it well the good the good news
is you don't live in an editor-dominated
world right i mean i had a meeting
yesterday internally of like
i've been thinking about pr for about
three years right now which is
should we create a vaynerx company that
does pr
pr does not exist the way everybody in
here just thought of it i
i actually think editors
are
leverageless
i think that they are pretty much being
affected by what happens online in
social and they're being affected up so
i think
first and foremost eliminating the
classic thinking of that that that is
even a thing i think can liberate you in
a big way
because it's just not
like you genuinely don't need them and
as someone who's been paying attention
very heavily to everything
going on in the business world
there's no brand that's being built
right now that is built by editors or pr
so i think you eliminate that
and i think the next question becomes
what are you going to do when it works
is actually what i'm more focused on so
what do i mean by that
i mean
for everybody here and it's going to get
repeated 100 times
i can't repeat it
enough the underpriced nature of tick
tock right now is just like the seventh
[ __ ] time this has happened and i'm
like you know like and it's really been
a fun one because i actually think by
the seventh time i've gotten enough
emails this time of like all right i
didn't do the instagram thing i didn't
do the facebook thing i didn't do the
search thing i didn't do the email thing
like i'm doing this one and it's working
it will work for you
on tick tock it will if you put out four
pieces of organic content a day
if you actually get your media and
create if you get your media
against creative right on tick tock it
will work in a way that you can't
imagine you can't imagine i'm telling
that to the majority of you it is
such scaled underpriced attention and
brand awareness
and
influence on instagram see people don't
think of things three-dimensionally
tick-tock's winning because
you're just getting a lot more eyeballs
for the price the price of your time the
price your content and definitely the
pricier media but it's also impacting
the content on instagram because it's
emerging as the cool thing it's almost
like the hottest club in new york
affecting like a good restaurant like
subconsciously people don't look at
these things this way but that's what
happens
and
progressive young editors are living in
that space deciding what they're going
to write about on their dot coms or in
print you know and so
i think that
for your business if i was your cmo i
would spend 80 percent of my time energy
and money on tick tock
80. and i think i'm my biggest detriment
because i'm in my 40s so i'm not used to
a camera following me around
you don't you don't need to go that
extreme right i remember when tick tock
first hit i was like
you don't have to dance just because
that's what for you know my i don't
dance i have 13 million followers i
haven't danced i can't dance it's not a
good thing he can dance but um
no honestly i don't you know couple
things one nobody here has to be the
face everyone can be the face i think
you should definitely do it i think it
would work
because you've got to understand one
thing that's interesting about tick tock
is
the reason tick tock so important even
for the b2b companies in here is there's
so many more 40 50 and 60 year olds on
the platform than people realize which
means people are underserving those ads
right so you're gonna have a wide gap
for a lot of people you will work for
other people it should be the product
for other people it should be the
influencers that you give
product to that you then use your
content but um
but that is absolutely where you should
be putting your time and energy i'll
tell you why it's important
there's only
it's just supply and demand there's just
moments when you go all in it's uh if
anybody plays poker i don't but i
definitely know this part when you
really know how to play poker and you're
looking at the board you know when you
have the single best hand you know it
because you know how to play poker and
you know of what you can see you have
the nuts or whatever it's called you go
all in
that's what i do in marketing when i
know a pro a platform is at enough scale
that it's hitting enough people
and the content organically is getting
seen by a lot of people
and the media is wildly underpriced
and
there hasn't been something this good
like tick tock this year since facebook
fan pages 2012.
that's a long time yeah
and if you think about the companies
that were built during that the
companies that were built during
instagram 2015-16
14 13 14 15 16.
um jim shark fashion nova
like
you can't do jim shark and fashion nova
today on instagram it's too expensive
right you can't do it tik tok is the
punch line
and you will crush on that platform and
i think
what i'm thinking through is
it's controversial because
you know
no matter how much a woman that has that
situation is affected that it's an
inconvenience popular culture doesn't
look at it as an inconvenience
and so what i think you need to be
thinking about is when it works
the level of
backlash that a lululemon or gym shark
wouldn't get you may get some in a world
where the world is so sensitive about
everything about everything about
everything and so like again if i was
the cmo i'd be like this is going to
work because we're going to just go all
in on tick tock i need to be
i would be thinking i need to make sure
she's ready for the level of comment
backlash and how are we going to deal
with that and what is our emotional and
strategic business positioning on it
because because visually it's going to
work
it just is and so
i think that's what you should be
thinking about um i definitely think
tick tock's big i think the other thing
you can do that can mitigate
what i'm referring to is to start a
podcast
right
where
you take the subject matter
of being different
left right being different in a good way
i mean being i mean i'm i look at trends
i think
beauty privilege is about to get
attacked very aggressively
like like it's just so obvious what's
shaping up like like that's gonna be
interesting like right like like we're
demonizing everything
um and so
i think a podcast of just
being different
one week you might have somebody who has
a disability terminal illness uh
a muscle-bound super dude who is
incredibly smart and people think he's a
doof like i think you could build a
platform for that which might work very
well as a compliment to dominating tick
tock
you see where i'm going yeah and
organically so with a limited budget
yeah so if you have a limited budget
this is why i'm pushing all of you in
the world and i have been as you many of
you follow me this is not a new song for
me it's just
it's it's at it's at it's like last
great year or two where it's
it's good because unlike three four
years ago it's older so you know four
years ago it was so young that if you're
selling something to 40 year olds it was
okay
now it's in that perfect year so you've
got another year you've got another 12
to 24 months minimally and i'll tell you
why tick tock is built on the interest
graph not on the social craft so what
you get is what you're into not who you
follow
in theory that's why i invested in
tumblr years ago and it worked out for
me i mean they didn't build it all the
way through it got bought by yahoo but i
but i don't say this because it was
historically not correct um but there
was a part of me that was more
enthusiastic about tumblr than facebook
and twitter when i invest in those three
companies and it was because i believed
that this the interest graph was more
interesting than the social graph
because i have tons of best friends but
we don't share all the same interests
i don't want to talk to my friend about
fishing that he's passionate about and
so i always thought that that was going
to be the big one so when tick-tock
started hitting i'm like oh [ __ ] here it
is
here's the thing i've been thinking
about
which also makes me believe that organic
may forever play on tick-tock
right in theory that shouldn't run out
of fatigue
um
i think they'll be government involved
i'm starting to try to figure out what's
going to happen with tick-tock in
america and china and all that but
i
organic will be great but i need to do
four a
day yeah like that's a whole different
game but that is like this is where i
get sad it's almost like working out
like doing the right things right when
you know
it's so everybody here who wants to get
into better shape
and physical conditioning i've got great
news eat cleaner and healthier and work
out
that's it
i'll see you next time same with this
people like i have a limited budget and
i'm like four tick tocks organically a
day they're like i'm like
we can't have both you don't have you
know the budget what you have is your
sweat equity
um i think it will really genuinely work
but then being great at tick tock is
what you need to think about like
actually understanding how it works
like skits and content and overlays but
not being scared to lose if you look at
my tic toc right now
my last 15 posts they can vary from 3
million views to 30 000 views and that's
not bad that just is what it is so don't
get down on it
but i mean look the reality is it's
gonna work it just is it's i know you
don't want guys gawking at the content
like that's not like it's just gonna
work because the people that are gonna
need to see it will see it
well my retention rate is ridiculous so
it's of course because and single digit
return rates which in dtc that's unheard
of you're gonna you're gonna win because
you're addressing a white space
you're gonna have a problem once you get
real traction because everyone's gonna
follow that um but for now let's get to
that problem
so
we've as i said we've been in business
80 some years kind of two segments of
our business a print for rewards and
recognition is kind of where it started
mostly in the medical field
and we've expanded out in the last 30
years into the uh more of a b2b print
space
my background has been with the fortune
100 so i was with 3m doing digital
marketing then app v which owns humera
which um so we ran that that center of
excellence um so very familiar with the
the digital space but um kind of trying
to james was saying yesterday you know
being the king of the pivot
as he called you you know as we think of
that
think of our our business the direct
marketing the print space um
and the evolution that that's taking
how would you how do you see that
evolution and where do we go
this is a challenging one because
there's more homework required for me to
truly answer you in the best way that i
can but i will say this
fighting
the the actual market is the scariest
thing of my life which is why i'm always
pivoting because i have no interest in
fighting the market
i assume for the rest of all of our
lives there'll be plenty of things
printed you know like even with nfts and
the metaverse everyone's like ah i'm
like
it's gonna take 50 years before we're
living in the metaverse the way people
are thinking it's going to happen
tomorrow it'll it will be living there
but it's gonna be and we live digitally
now most of us are on our phones four
six nine hours a day
so um
i i think the thing that you need to
figure out is in declining market share
so is the overall market declining
double digits each year like really
intensely
yeah it depends on what segment you're
looking at but yes yeah my intuition is
this becomes a very simple game of like
real life meaning
real life
what would you like to happen you know
there's the ideology part which is this
has been a business in the family for a
long time
and so you might be emotionally invested
in that story and want it to continue
and so thus you need to heavily innovate
into
the way i think about what nintendo did
nintendo started as a playing card
company
they are not that today
so i think
if you want to see this business last
past you because of it's the way it's
gone you're gonna have to be in a
different business
because i don't think it'll be
sustainable
uh if you don't mind because you think i
don't know what your children's
situation or you know
then then you've got to dominate market
share until you're ready to be done
that's the actual answer to this
business question
do you start a completely different
business
that could be tangentially attached to
it your printing infrastructure might be
the reason you started direct to
consumer book business
it might be
but you could literally go into a
completely different business
you could as a division whether it's
making board games making digital games
you could go anywhere
um
but
but you're not going to change
the market right the market's going to
keep doing what it's doing yeah and i
think
and especially with nfts coming
like what's going to end up happening is
because they're going to be utilities
people are going to go away from
emailing qr codes to nfts let alone
print so it's going to put more pressure
on the overall philosophy and as you
know
every day there's a decision maker dying
or retiring that has held on to print
and the person taking that job
is not doing print yeah and that puts
pressure
and i guess i have no
no tied to the actual machine putting
ink on paper right correct i
find you know we try to help local
businesses find attract engage and
retain right i mean the whole life cycle
that we're talking about which is
evolving into it but you have so
you have some so many cogs into your
infrastructure
you could to your point if you want to
build a digital
division we've seen that happen for the
last 25 years plenty of people in the
print direct mail business and all the
versions of it have done that
i'm challenging you to that's the easy
thing to think about because we've
watched companies like yours do that for
the last 25 years
i think service providing even though i
do it at scale is a [ __ ] business it's
not fun yes sir so you know
what one opportunity is to take your
infrastructure and create a consumer
business instead of a service business
i always like to think that way of like
well we've got these assets we can make
[ __ ] should we make something to sell
obviously a totally different gear of
being in b to c than b to b
um
but it's a good time to debate it
what's funny is it's not our consumer
business but like the etsy world
has been coming like we've been growing
as
the creatives
are creative but they have no outlet to
actually produce so it almost becomes
more of a wholesale model but it is
they're looking and that
big supply chain sucks to do if
anybody's you know outsourced to anybody
oftentimes sucks 100 you know they
they're they're not good at responding
and so we're like hey can we take our
family you know feel where it's a high
touch you know personal and say
you're going to get that personal aspect
of that business right the answer is yes
and then it becomes a game of marketing
on linkedin and and google search and
pre-roll youtube to win that market
share
so the other piece of our business
people are going to always make things
on paper
till the end i just think it's the way
you position it and where you decide to
market against which behaviors to your
point etsy didn't exist 20 years ago
thanks and so the other piece of our
business is an awards and recognition
space we have been in the medical space
so if you go to your doctor and they're
board certified i've printed that
certificate oh interesting business for
80 years yep started with nursing pins
when you had to have a pin on your hat
right when you went it's cool that's
evolved out but they still print these
really high-end certificates we do all
that printing all that framing for them
that brings us to the nft okay so
they're laggards so literally i'm like
hey can you make us a pdf so they can go
to the hospital and you know show them
certificate because we have doctors like
ripping out their certificates out of
frames in order to show it to a hospital
to say that
it's nuts and it's like it still goes
but they're not willing to even invest
because a lot of them don't those boards
are not big money they're a big
you know there's only a few people in
some of them but they own that space if
you're a surgeon you have to be board
certified right like that you don't work
in a hospital without being board
certified so
we're trying to help but you need to
have the manifestation in physical form
like a lot of times yeah or they call
and they'll get a letter from the board
i mean there's just a lot of things that
we are trying to
yeah just the proof that they have been
and you know they'll get a physical
letter from the board saying that
they're more certified and some are more
involved than
yeah that is a that is a out of central
casting of a business that's going to be
disrupted by the blockchain yeah and
yeah so how do you compete how do
you're thinking the right way you cr to
your point you create it so
something out it's always the same thing
put yourself out of business before
someone else does
i think the way you need to think about
it is get incredibly educated and become
the creative and infrastructure that
builds the board certified nfts
you do them in nft form
always starting tomorrow but you print
it and give it to them still and then in
a cycle of 15 years you'll have that
leverage it's almost like the evolution
of the pin that your grandfather you
know started you you do it now
so you are that
and the market comes to you because
there's not a very heavy cost for you to
do it yeah so
launched the brand about um
i guess five months ago
and what's the distribution distribution
is right now i can service the eastern
half of canada direct to consumer okay
and as of next week or the week after
anywhere in the us
leveraging uh amazon's multi-channel
most sales are through shopify website
at byworkwater.com right from the
eastern canada part yeah yep and that'll
be the same thing for us so understood
my shopify site amazon fulfilled i see
and um
so the only place somebody can buy it is
on your.com in like 30 local stores that
i'm servicing yep i'm having the
conversations starting to have the
conversations with retailers
contributors but the lead time on all
that is so long i want to immediately
focus on direct consumer that will help
me build leverage with those confidence
100
and drive sales so i can make this
available on your own data
yeah
um
so right now i'm at the point next week
launching two new flavors so this one is
the original it's like a cream soda with
notes of coconut
10 calories sweet vestivia the other two
are lemon and blue raspberry
so pretty excited about that
and
two weeks ago hired a full-time paid
intern to start hosting tick-tocks
full-time so he's doing about four
videos a day very good two weeks have
been good good
um active mostly on instagram and
facebook which has just been kind of
organic local community that is followed
up behind the brand yep all sales today
put down about 25 000 the last few
months all our new media just reaching
out to the local paper the
nightly news picked it up
so that's been kind of the journey today
and so now where i'm at is so it's been
a calm for five months
right uh yeah yeah that's right and
how much like what kind of sales are you
at so twenty five thousand dollars in
sales period in that five months
and how much is it
it sells for uh thirty dollars for
twelve pack thirty dollars for twelve
pack
that's canadian canadian yeah us will be
similar in u.s dollars got it
i know i got it yep uh but target is to
price it similar to you know a monster
energy like a premium other unhealthy
energy drink i want to just not be too
cost differentiated from those to make
it accessible
so right now um i'm at the point where
i've got production good
distribution is now in place and i need
to
build awareness make people
consider it or from the website
doing the tick tock thing how much money
are you going to have for marketing this
year
as
what i'd like to figure out quickly is
um
how i can drive sales like i people that
like the product love it and reorder
like my customer lifetime value i think
is going to be quite high it's still too
new to get some data on that but i would
love like i've ran some facebook
instagram ads and for every hundred
dollars i run i get about 250 in sales
just with like straight up call to
action buy this because like
so one thing that will get way more
expensive at scale
that's the problem but
i feel like i can reach a threshold of
you know that working to get enough
sales that so my scenario is i've had to
extract myself out of working for
another company for 15 years the last
three years have been
starting up my own company switched to
have you have have you have you raised
capital no but i've saved that money so
the last few years i've been doing
consulting as a contractor and so i've
got
would you be open to raising capital
i would sue i think
you you want you want more
well you know you know it's it's a fair
question i mean i think it's you know to
your point and to your point i mean
it you probably want to build up more
leverage to get a better valuation that
makes sense
i also believe that we are in the
greatest era of
money being printed
in perpetuity with no logic thus
investing
is wild out there and you've got people
that are literally writing 25 and 100
000 checks that have no business
doing that and maybe you can prey on
that you know to your advantage um it's
something worth thinking about because i
what i'm most concerned about is
beverage direct to consumer is hard
like
in the direct to consumer hardcore spot
shopify mafia all the kids that left
there in the last decade who are like
the experts that run around the world
literally the first meeting you have
with any of them gareth robbie all these
guys and gals i know
the if you talk anything about dtc the
first question i'll ask is you're not
doing beverage are you
that's how fearful it is because of how
competitive
the margins and how heavy it is to ship
and i always have a lot of empathy
because i built a large direct consumer
wine business and
every day i'm like man i wish my dad had
a food store instead of a wine store
because i would have built a much bigger
company um
so i think
the reason and you know a lot of you
have probably had a good sense of my
content for a long time like i knew i
rarely go to capital first it's like
doesn't really come out of my mouth i
don't even think like ever um but
i think you're gonna find yourself there
i really genuinely do
on the flip side
luckily we have this one thing going on
right now it's called tick tock it is
absolutely the wild card for you
you know
obviously it's going to be the variable
of how good that intern is or you are
but i think
sending
product to micro micro micro influencers
if we're gonna do the scrappy thing
which is what you're doing
i'm i'm here for it i think what you
need to do is find people that have ten
to a hundred thousand followers on tick
tock and send them
three cans two cans one can at a time
i mean this is literally what i did back
in the day so i did this for years i
know this game
it works but it is a [ __ ] grind you
know shipping one can at a high cost per
ship of the can
times 47 different people a day
times
getting to 47 people to give you their
address times only four of those 47
actually post when it's all said and
done
but it's there for you it's there for
you so i'm absolutely up for that and
the reason i made the opaque answer
investment was i made a conscious
decision that
i've got some money saved up i can start
this i can build it to a good enough
point that you'll have leverage
yep conversation so i think we're
getting closer to that yeah i think
facebook ads are still an incredibly
efficient thing obviously with ios 14.5
update where you can't re target there's
a little bit of a excuse me
excuse me uh thank you everyone uh
there's a little bit of like a bigger
challenge but i think given the category
that you have much like the first
business we talked about i think you're
primed for a tic tac tick tock excuse me
and tick tocks uh um invasion what i
would recommend for both of you and a
couple more coming up is actually spend
15 to 30 actual hours
really studying it
you know like what's amazing about is
you could really do anything
and you can learn through doing anything
but
really understanding it i think is uh
you know hashtags trends
just really being in it it is definitely
your calling card
when
when
and soon for you when something hits
virality turning that into a performance
ad
is a huge opportunity so now you have
organic virality
then you rejigger that slightly with the
copy
maybe even with the content but probably
not too much because you don't want to
take away the magic and turn that into a
paid ad
for conversion
very very big opportunity
do you think you can ask many questions
and one of the things those who say on
your debt side
you could do it also with debt on the
performance of your so you can instead
of maintaining your very good dollars
right so what you would do is somebody
said okay you go out and perform x y z
and we're going to take a percentage off
those sales you still keep your equity
yeah and you have a great canadian
company right clear bank i think yeah
right so
there's a lot of options but
i think i think again the category
you're in is very conducive to tick tock
um and so i re i really don't want you
to rely just on the intern i want you to
put in the 15 to 30 hours it's your
business
awesome
i'll sneak this yeah
thank you um so if i end up getting time
cool yeah let's
go to fat scooters yeah guys so let's
start with the macro economic backdrop
i'm like chris yep we're at the early
stages of a massive
you know right the reverse opportunity
yeah vehicles eat it chris
you know i gotta take this start
tens and hundreds of trillions are the
estimates of what the future value of
this marketplace is so great
macroeconomic trail wins the mic which
which comes with a lot of its own
headaches too well it really does yeah
it does and the microeconomics are now
really good because we fixed it done
and and the branding
for our niche in the industry has been
really strong we have a premium product
it's recognized as a premium product
we drive
60 percent plus gross margins now thanks
to 10
exceptional work on bill materialism
positioning
um
you know
and so
and we have a great
customer base because we have
a celebrity and high profile a laundry
list hundreds and hundreds how much is
it
about four thousand dollars all in after
you accessorize everybody everything's
better than music um
and so and we've got these you know
celebs and
professional athletes who have paid real
money full price
for our products
okay what is that
keep going good and so um
so the previous management team you know
they did some nice you know going from
zero to three is different than going
from three to thirty of course three
hundred
so
you know they were very much i thought
they were very narrow and appropriate
parochial in their vision
we're
sort of
changing the conversation from being a
electric
micro mobility
company
one second
is it all direct to consumer it has been
historically
we have maybe something that's more
unique than what other people have which
is we have to have service in warranty
service and out of warranty customer
service that's a good business doing
that out of phoenix
doesn't make sense and we have both
yeah so we have you know you have you
know the interesting thing about the
product my quality is because i work on
it every day no worries go ahead so
you look at apple yep right we all
understand that
i went out and i did all the field work
and when i found out our consumer is
supposedly a young it's not right
consumer's a 60 year old man
right it's 98 of our sales are 30 years
old and above
but when i got out in the field i said
well wait a minute we thought that i
thought stupidly that they had to write
it first
that's what you would think
and then when i actually asked him
71
of our consumer had never ridden the
unit
so then that
gives you
right he bought one and we talked about
this last night so 71 bought it then
when i started to ask him how long have
you seen it once a few times never
81 never saw it and they bought it on
site
so that's apple ask type numbers when
you get that type of conversion so what
i'm interested in is i don't know if i'm
a finance background and so i i would
take it public like because right now in
this market i started here in 91 in new
york and i remember the nasdaq talking
about cisco and i thought it was the
food company
right oh who's these guys what's tim
claire i should have known right
so um but the point i'm making is is
that i feel it's very similar in that
space there's only certain survivors of
course right but we we aren't micro
mobility we're urban mobility we're 3 to
30 miles
average person travels 23 miles a day i
mean think about new york it's nine
miles
right 23 miles a day and a 4094 pound
vehicle
so we we can take you 30 35 miles i'm
260 pounds
right so we're not talking about the
slider you know yeah of course we're
talking about average americans so what
i'm interested in is do we grow it and
do i exchange that value for what i can
hit today
um
i
you know it's weird because i'm not a
founder you know you rebain capitals
founders mentality and you look at this
now brought a founder's mentality to the
company after the fact
but it's interesting because i've never
been the situation it's throughput
right i have to make it i have to sell
it and i have to make those match at the
exact same time never had that
experience before yeah services
but you know how miserable those can be
of course because they call you
so what i'm looking for is you know how
how can how can this group help us you
know with a that decision i believe in
tick tock tremendously we just did one
um just with the crew after we finished
at the up asia lp
pga and the lpga event at lake nona and
it was like 17 000 like immediate and it
was just us like great
right now no one famous yep
but so i really want to know like what
your thoughts are in the space and you
know there's we're not a scooter
we're not a scooter that i know we are
not a scooter we are fat rods and so
hence i bought the name but
that's what i want to stay with so i
just love your thoughts because
well i think it's it yeah i think i
appreciate that i think it's about
reverse engineering because the one
thing i heard there is do i take it
public right i mean
obviously i'm sure the three of you
thought through
that
little moment of spax and things of that
nature right of course and so
i i you know it's really just the a
different version of raising capital
like it's all about timing of what you
want the outcome to be i
i always when there's moments like i
just referenced with like something like
tick-tock and i'm glad that you've
already had that micro little taste
anytime i see such an arbitrage in
consumer growth at an underpriced rate i
never want to transact because i want to
capture that value
right i would rather you know back to f
up i think financially right like like
i'll sell in the mo in the down cycles
of like oh like i even was at vayner
like three years ago pre tick-tock i'm
like we're in a weird spot right now
there is no heavy arb instagram's
maturing right if you think about it
like organic content was not a
conversation like we knew we were we
were like i was like [ __ ] and sure
enough thank god musically came and tick
tock came but like there is those
moments so i think
my hot take and there's a couple
follow-up questions but is if you're
going to capture
that opportunity then you capture it
because you have more leverage with that
especially when money is so cheap right
um it also becomes a game of do you have
the appetite and the capabilities to do
that
yeah i mean we're a veteran debt and the
only reason is because i did venture yep
right and the venture side is everybody
records you like i look like a really
attractive woman like my wife yes right
and i quartered her but then all of a
sudden you have her and they take
advantage of it
[Laughter]
oh vc's i couldn't agree i mean it's the
most fascinating thing
i mean you only need one of those
companies to hit and so you're playing
that game subconsciously even if you
don't realize you're doing it they don't
care and so on the dead side you have to
talk to me yeah right i played the other
game yeah so
um and had success and it's been fine
but the reality is is that when you're
on the debt side you either pay your
mortgage or you don't we know what the
outcome is mm-hmm
so i'm i'm in a bevy of you know more of
a venture i'm a private equity type of
guy so you have kind of like two
different lanes what's the revenue of
the business now about six million and
what was that the year i mean covet
throws everything it's so hard to get
like it took the seven million dollars i
think it's a lie because they did 1.4
million of giveaways
right for their friends family and
everybody else
so we'll do 12 million this year
you're tracking already
yeah that's great the problem all dtc
still all knows no
the the 12 yeah
it's layering on the authorized dealer
and golf network and golf and there's
golf b to b
so we have right now we have seven it's
b to be the same 70 courses have
purchased our units but it's the
consumer that's buying it and taking it
to their course
but the courses that are buying it they
buy their direct units and they hold
them in their fleet right and it's
theirs no the consumer's not buying it
off of them
so it's that's truly b2b but in some of
the country club courses the country
club is actually buying it
in bulk on behalf of the members who
live around
foreign is that is there an opportunity
to
like i mean those
businesses are also trying to extract
and find new revenue streams and they're
getting challenges or an opportunity to
treat every country club in america as
our dealerships
so we could you floorboard to magnetic
yeah you can switch it and they're like
that's why i take that call out yeah the
drew barrymore show and they want the
scooter now on site that's what i
pitched yesterday and they said oh
you're right we want it here not a
picture
she wants to interact with it makes
sense so with the floorboard i made it
through bear more yeah it's a magnetic
so i can flip it and like at golf
courses every
four weeks
in bed will pay 108 180 a week a month
for that ad because they get 60
impressions i totally understand right
so that's that's where is that something
that you can share in that revenue yes
you think you can build that moat with
the
are you leasing the units to the country
clubs that's the key
yeah go ahead go ahead please one of the
things that is that there's this
national movement
like we were talking last night golf is
meant to be kind of a single person
thing and we're stuck in a cart and i'm
going to his ball and he's going to my
ball
golf course is for single rider play
right you do you i do me we meet up at
the eighteenth of nineteen fold and have
a drink kind of a thing
it's
pga or somebody did a study that they
can get four to six more forces per day
through if it's single writer play well
if you're paying 100 bucks or 200 bucks
a whack for a round interesting
that's real money
that's very interesting
yes 16 450 courses yeah
so they they know the flights you need
the planes in the air
is the b2b
business happening serendipitously you
have a sales team what's what's
happening with that you have two sales
people
and you
i understand um
yeah i mean so two two things one
the my second favorite arbitrage and
marketing right now behind tick tock is
linkedin
and so the reason i was going down that
path i'm like [ __ ] these guys really
have a situation that could be fun here
if they can get their content and media
engines right on tick tock and linkedin
and obviously the linkedin is
literally being targeted against
employees or the private equity firms
the board members like you're literally
actually targeting the person that would
make the decision like literally you can
i mean i don't know if linkedin gives
you this option so we'd have to look but
whatever the job description is
of the people that
run country clubs you know if they have
a common thing or it's presence of this
but like the other great thing about
golf is it's such a passion point that
even if you go broad high net worth and
say pass this on to your country club
like i do a lot of that kind of
marketing that people don't think about
which is just hit the lower cost
broadness and literally in the copy say
pass this on to your country club you're
like okay like people actually like the
one great thing about humans is they
actually listen just tell them what to
do and so yeah i know we're scaling just
because like the masters reach out to us
that's huge they want us to be around
the whole week and i'm like a year ago
they were like look you have a b to b
and a b to c business and i think
tick tock and linkedin are in their
primes and i think what you need to
leave with is understanding the media
and the creative on those two platforms
i think you'll grow a lot thank you
thank you
um so i think for me so uh in particular
started out as just like more of like me
being the content creator so of course
four years like
do you like you know knowing what you're
doing so well and i think i've been
thinking about it for a decade do you
like the content part
more or do you like yeah of course i've
heard
it's exhausting because
that's exhausting
yeah is so you're excited about the
fanny pack 6.0 that you're creating both
because i feel like they work hand in
hand yeah the particulars has allowed me
to build this community of women correct
all of the people i've interviewed
where did the interviews live
so they live on a website right now
which
and what's the what's the is it video
no it's audio no well oh it's written
no [ __ ] don't do that
that's a huge option i'm so pumped
because now i'm like [ __ ] she's been
able to build pretty well and you're
doing it written yeah so it's all so
easily
interview the person ever voice record
it then it's transcribing you should put
that voice recording out right that's
the question so do i take these hundred
interviews no no
you know what i'm worried about because
the audio was made without the context
that it's gonna be a podcast there could
be [ __ ] in there that's almost more work
than [ __ ] you know
yeah exactly exactly and you and that
means you'd have to re-listen to
everyone because you don't want to put
out something that you said or that
person so no i think what i would do is
start video from the next interview
and
do video
extract audio and transcribe to written
so the where does the video live
in on the website on the internet well
no i know that but i mean
oh by the way more people watch it
naturally just in youtube than they will
by going to your site right okay it
lives on the internet
like you know it's it's an interesting
kind of like it's the now accepted 2.0
thinking but you're caught in 1.5
internet 1.5 thinking and we just have
to move you it lives on the internet not
only that oh by the way if you look at
anything i do i'm wildly busy
this entire program is
not a very good use of my time if he was
analyzing it except that i'm literally
making it worth my time by filming it
and the filming
is in its entirety but also in its
chopped up pieces and if i can make four
of them
get the 12 million views on linkedin it
becomes worth my time
so like i want all of you to do that
which is like in theory
you're starting from a macro your show
and then it's creating not only because
right now you're taking an hour or 30
minutes or how long are you interviewing
an hour total
an hour
and you're only getting written output
where in the way i see it when you get
video content for instagram and tick
tock and stuff like that but that's more
of like you do it
yeah you have to almost like restart
whereas what i just want you to do is
correct
you don't have to i mean it's amazing
now as you know yeah or you're on stream
yard or riverside or youtube live you
can go live
and start like they're just a much more
efficient model of like
do the video thing get the written get
the audio and get the post-production
micro pieces out of it
all of a sudden you're getting so much
more for your time yeah mm-hmm okay and
then also like just pushing the nice
back out there into the world and
developing other products coming out of
that mattress that to me is what this is
actually about yeah i think you're
the reason i was kind of like if you
notice i listened but i jumped into
yours i i think you're you're naturally
subconsciously building the right thing
and i want to keep giving you that push
which is
okay now you're going to take it from
your subconscious to your conscious i'm
building a media company to sell stuff
it's how i started this company i don't
want a service business as i've made
clear three times now
but but in in these 13 years
i incubated rezzy which i sold amex for
200 million i incubated empathy wines
which i sold to 200 million i incubated
v friends which i don't even i mean
every one of those companies
were done by people that were trained
here
and so like i view this as my operating
system to actual because i believe that
actual marketing is the only thing
that's not commoditizable
like everything else can get caught up
on patents aren't real anymore like
everything can be caught up to the
ability to every day by the second be a
day trader of communication
is impossible which is why everyone is
coming to me and other people that have
that skill set whether it's politics or
selling water and so i kind of want you
to do the same thing which is like your
media is your moat but then because you
know you're making it your moat for your
next pat thing
you might even start really thinking
what do you want that next thing to be
and then do you start interviewing that
way backwards so if you know you're
passionate about flowers
you might start strategically having
five guests in a three-month period all
in the flower business because you're
attracting audience which then you see
what i mean that
but you have to change the way you're
doing the interviews yeah um mine are
more like technical things yeah guys
we're a little bit more like we're
our content game is um you know we're at
that plateau stage where like we did
well it's at a certain level we you know
it's kind of staying stagnant makes
sense what do you think if you guys have
if the three of you can jump in what do
you what do you think is happening if
you had to like be totally naked about
it what do you think's happening is it a
platform thing is that you're just doing
the same [ __ ] is it him is it you is it
i think so i'm going to chime in here a
little bit but i think that like we're
producing a lot of content we have three
uh video editors content creators um i'm
sifting for trends he's using the
platforms um we use scheduling tools and
everything but it's a matter of like
um
i guess how many times a day we're
posting
versus like how much content we have
that's unique
um on we're really trying to grasp tick
tock some of the stuff that's been
working like obviously stuff about
rentals in section 8 because it's drama
people love that stuff
i've heard drama works it does but we
also want to like we
we want to structure it as like a
learning experience
a fun experience one thing to think
about this will help all of you is too
many people want social content to do
everything instead of being the moose
boosh to the thing you want them to do i
think for example i would tell you that
i'm incredibly misunderstood as a
businessman because my social media
content can't do the depths of what i do
there is no videos where i'm talking
like this where i can i like who i am as
an actual business person does not
really show up with my social i just let
my social
do the appetizer part and then with the
hopes that people will go down the path
and a lot of times where you have depth
and you have a real business
you get caught up because you're trying
to make a little bit more happen in the
content which doesn't mean being
authentic and just do whatever will work
on social
but
but think strategically of like what
will this tick tock do when they decide
to click the default url in our profile
instead of maybe trying to make two or
three things happen in a piece
does that make sense
yeah
yeah um i want to start with the 3d
printing okay so
that's about to so essentially we have
you guys all seen 3d printing yeah of
course we have a massive gantry style 3d
printer that extrudes concrete that
prints houses there's five companies in
the entire country that do that we're
doing things that none of them are
meaning we're doing we're 3d printing
the forms the foundations into your next
year walls no wood inside we're also
very close to launching taking recycled
plastic bottles to build the doors
cabinets moldings so cool we just got
approvals to do
uh roofs also so it's 50-year warranties
40 cheaper 40 faster it's amazing how
long does it take two guys build a house
with a robot it takes 40 print hours to
print the forms of the footings the
foundations and the interior and
exterior walls before how big is the
house
okay however we maybe want to put it in
is is that a perimeter foundation or
slab right now it's live on grade
number two which is coming out um in the
next quarter is going to be able to do
two stories and basements is it
insurable by the banks yes it is so we
just spec build two good question
all right that's a great question yeah
oh it was it was i was like great catch
you just spec build so a couple of
problems a like the technology is now
like
i was stalling my partner i was like
stole social because the technology a
lot of guys went out like there's a
company called icon i remember
i remember
yeah and i'm like don't raise money
i think they're coming out of the gate
too hard too fast the technology isn't
there the adoption
um municipalities have to be able to
understand issue permits we receive the
first 3d printed permit um in the
country that's cool so our eye contact
was in texas there was no zoning you
could just do it we did it new york
which is the hardest place of course
so my thing is now we did that house
kind of like under the cover of night
nobody really saw it i'm about to do one
in a place called islandia and now we're
getting the approvals in riverhead
island to do
uh 25 lots of subdivision which will be
the biggest 3d printed subdivision in
the world
and i want to bring it out but we have
the issue with obviously adoption
locally from the municipalities
understanding in the building
departments and how do we make the
consumer
understand like this is what it is this
is why it's better faster
stronger
why do you need the consumer
to know what it is well
understand like i tell somebody with 3d
printing in a house like
why does that matter
for a couple reasons a
pressure on the municipalities at the
end of the day for all the smoke and
mirrors it's a concrete house of course
he's doing it forever 100 it's not a big
deal that's where i'm going with this
like at the end of the day the consumer
is going to care about the price
yes the municipalities don't listen to
the consumer
you don't have enough the money you'll
need to get
enough consumers to make enough
municipalities to listen is going to be
a really interesting
you know whiteboard session that
probably is going to play like to me why
not just wait it out
why not do
keep doing what you're doing we are but
we are but it's like so now we're gonna
we want to kind of unveil this the world
so i was gonna live stream the build
every day to show people how it worked
that's exactly right yeah um i just
wanna make sure that
for me it's kind of no different than
[ __ ] the editors
it's like [ __ ] the municipalities ju
do exactly what you're doing hand to
hand combat
and then literally build youtube shows
and just like let and what's great about
it is and you can see it it's still such
a good story that you're one
moment away from the whole thing
exploding in the best way possible so i
just think it becomes a game of just
like
don't even it's why it was why my series
of questions was going the way it was
going don't worry about anything except
the execution yeah no that makes sense
um you know sometimes when you're
country original you're in like your own
little world working on it you have to
come out to the world to talk about it
like
oh am i crazy yeah
um
yeah
when you innovate after the need for
affirmation
is really fascinating because it really
goes one of two ways
i've been very fortunate this luck of
the dna draw i
not only don't need it i almost don't
want it the longer i can be innovating
without anybody understanding what i'm
doing the happier i am
i think for other people there is that
need and that's also awesome and i think
you should feed that because it's
oxygen
and i think content along the way will
give that to you because it's going to
come from strangers instead of maybe you
know people in your space which i think
is important to think about yeah we're
also just we're exploring different
verticals with it like are we you know
we're selling machines i'm like you know
i don't i don't want to go out and be a
builder per se of 3d printed has
although we're doing it to showcase the
product it's
it's a lot do you own the technology
yeah no we own it we have a patent on
the on the tip
that extrudes the conduit
yeah
so um
that i want to understand that last line
it's a lot meaning
it's so
a lot of people are going to jump on
that bandwagon 100
obviously housing
as simple as it is because the machine
is very simple
it's not that simple to put it together
people are having a hard time getting it
to work yep we feel that we've really
mastered it so my thing is how do we get
to as many people as humanly possible
when you're talking about because you're
trying to sell the machine well that's
the thing like my partner i talk about
it all the time i'm like is this a
license to play are we just selling the
machines and then we're selling it for x
and then you know per square foot we're
getting a residual on what you're
printing i love it but um so there's
that there's you know are we actually
going out and building since we have
this technology that enables us to build
things at 40 less but
i flip over
the construction
oh yeah yeah it gets commoditized down
and everybody's going to just take the
yes
the consumer's going to benefit from
what you're doing
you're not going to capture you're not
going to capture those economics yeah i
flip over 100 houses a year in new york
which is like a nightmare like it's just
a logistical nightmare between you know
everything
so that's what i'm saying like what's
the pathways resistance to get this in
the hands of as many people as possible
that can go out and do these things so
we're not doing it i think the thing you
can control right now is building up the
reputation and brand yeah
people are always fascinated early in my
career of why i would my dad was [ __ ]
always angry at me it was like giving
away the secrets i'm like they're not
secrets
i'm not giving away the secret
everyone's gonna know this in three
years i'm gonna own the conversation
i didn't invent nfts i didn't give away
the secrets but i have the
now that's what you should do yeah and
as
leverage
i'm thinking i would be the authority on
3d printing 100 because as we all think
of like what the best because there's
three or four paths all of that becomes
it's oh i always talk about like floyd
mayweather versus mike tyson
when you sit on stuff like this everyone
feels like you want to mike tyson it
like go out and [ __ ]
and to me it's like
just continue to build the leverage be
smart take fights that are easy and then
in the ring react to what's happening so
build the leverage
on awareness and then you'll have
options to decide what you want to do
inevitably it might come to you
one more real quick okay perfect so on
the on the fix and flip side
again we do over 100. my goal is to do
200 before i transition out because i
literally think it will it will kill me
um we our client is but that's an
arbitrary number like why not why not
235 or 175. no of course yeah just yeah
i've heard you say yeah yeah it's just
real
because it helps because then you get
into some [ __ ] up things when you
actually fall in love with the arbitrary
number it's just like for me i feel like
nothing changed and you're like this
sucks i'm very like obsessive and
addicted with things so it's like i feel
like and i feel like i have to be the
best in what i do before i ultimately
get bored and move on to the next thing
so that you've decided that's the number
i get it i respect that okay
so our our cluster customer is basically
the person that's going to sell us a
house and we've had a either they're
losing it for one reason or another
either it's destroyed whatever and we
have a hard time advertising on the
platforms and things because we're
restricted because of you know whether
it's financial issues they're having or
whatever it is like
it's harder to target those people 100
you just need general awareness
like like targeting is new
like print direct mail radio
television it was all broad
right so you know
thank god tick tock is cheap broad
got it yeah no you can target by
location yeah and that's what you can do
100 and again i said it subtly it's
important for you guys
the wording
where everybody makes a mistake is
here's the ad and it says do you have
and the answer is i don't when you say
does anybody you know have i go my aunt
does and i forward it
copy
you know even from mad men to today copy
just like everything that the last hour
the variable of what you thought was
completely predicated on every word out
of my mouth the copy
so notice what i just did it's not do
you have a house to sell or do you have
this situation do you or anyone you know
yeah
it's [ __ ] insane you don't even want
to know what that's going to mean to
your conversion that little [ __ ]
thing
it's one of the things i learned when i
was getting referrals because i was
doing [ __ ] 100
i just said you know anybody that's it
i don't even i don't even say you i only
start with do you know anybody
because there's a funny reaction of like
well me i'm like okay great let's do
that business
you know
[Music]
hiring is guessing firing is knowing
like you got to go fast that's how you
get [ __ ] done that's how you figure
stuff out this
is the television
and the television is the radio
the 40s [ __ ]